- This little rock has
come from the bottom
of the Pacific Ocean,
some 14,000 feet down.
Now, it may look like a lump of coal,
but it's actually dense with cobalt,
nickel, manganese, and copper,
some of the key minerals in EV batteries.
The fact that a company has
been to the bottom of the ocean
and brought this to the surface
shows just how far we're now willing to go
in the hunt for the minerals
that will power our electric vehicles.
See, as demand for electric
vehicles increases,
the need for their critical minerals
is set to explode
and dramatically outpace supply.
That's pushed some startups
to pioneer new techniques
that could fundamentally reshape
how we find and extract
the minerals for our batteries.
So, what do the different tiers
of EV battery mineral mining look like?
(calm music)
Let's start with this rock.
It's a test sample that comes from here,
a huge area 1000 miles
off the coast of Mexico
called the Clarion Clipperton Zone.
And down there our rock
isn't exactly a rare find.
There are thousands of
these potato-sized nodules.
Holding another one of them
is The Metals Company CEO, Gerard Barron.
- We're very fortunate that our nodules
actually lay on the ocean floor,
a little bit like golf
balls on a driving range.
We don't have to go and dig, or drill,
or tunnel to find them,
they're literally laying there
waiting for us to pick them up.
- The company's plan is to
send down robots like this
to collect the nodules
and bring them up to the
surface for processing.
Now, while companies have wanted
to mine these fields for decades,
a combination of technological limitations
and regulatory hurdles
have prevented anyone from
exploiting the resource.
But, that could all change
if and when the UN's
International Seabed Authority
finalizes its regulations
on seabed mining.
So far the governing body has given out
22 licenses to contractors
to explore the ocean floor,
but not to mine it.
- It's a bit of a land grab
and I think as we move closer
to the final mining code being adopted,
which we expect no later than 2025,
countries are awakening to the fact
that this is an enormous economic
and national security opportunity.
- [George] But, as with most mining,
deep-sea mining isn't
without its controversy,
especially as thousands of new species
have been discovered down there.
Some groups have called for an
outright ban of the practice.
Meanwhile, countries like Canada
and companies like BMW and Volvo
have asked for progress to be paused
until protection of the marine habitat
can be guaranteed.
The Metals Company says that its operation
will have the lightest impact
on the marine ecosystem.
- Some people wanna move forward
in a very precautionary manner, as do we,
that's why we've spent now
more than 400 million dollars
to fully understand those impacts.
- Now, while our ocean floor minerals
have been known about for decades,
finding new deposits to mine
can be challenging and time consuming.
It usually involves
setting off seismic charges
or taking core samples
and then spending weeks
analyzing that data.
But, startup Fleet Space says
that its satellite network
could change that.
- We do an ultrasound for Mother Earth.
We can't wait 15 years
to find each new deposit,
as has been the case in mining before.
- [George] The company deploys a grid
of ambient noise tomography
sensors in the ground
that pick up natural micro-vibrations.
- They listen to the ambient
rumbling of the earth
and generate a three-dimensional
image of the subsurface
down to about 2.5 kilometers.
- The data from those sensors
is then collected in real time
by a network of satellites,
which send it off for instant processing.
Fleet Space says that
this gives its customers,
who includes the likes of
mining giant Rio Tinto,
the ability to know what
might lie beneath them
within days, as opposed to months.
The company told me that usually
it can take around
600,000 meters of drilling
to find a new deposit.
- No one really wants to do that
and governments don't want to allow people
to just drill at random
until they hit things either.
We don't want to turn the
world into Swiss cheese
looking for the metals
that are gonna sustain
our energy transition.
- But there's one potential
source of these minerals
that doesn't involve going
to the bottom of the ocean
or drilling lots of holes.
It involves utilizing a resource
that is right in front of you right now,
recycling old batteries.
According to analysts,
there's already around 650,000
tons of battery minerals
in the US alone
in cars, phones, laptops,
and other industrial sources.
And startup, Redwood Materials,
formed in 2017 by former
Tesla CTO, JB Straubel,
has the ambition of
recovering the minerals
stored in those items
when they reach the end of their life,
turning them back into battery materials.
The company says they do this
by discharging the batteries
and dismantling them into
their individual components.
Those components are then shredded
and turned into something
called black mass,
which goes through
hydro-metallurgic process
to isolate the critical minerals.
Redwood says this will enable it
to extract 30% of the lithium and nickel
and 100% of the cobalt
needed to made a cathode.
The problem is,
while there's set to be
lots more EVs on the market
over the coming decade,
it will be several more years
before the batteries in today's EVs
reach the end of their useful life
and need to be recycled.
So, right now the company
is mainly recycling
batteries from portable electronic devices
as well as manufacturing scrap,
the waste product that's created
when making batteries.
That's still enough for
the company to get through
40,000 metric tons of
recyclable material a year,
though it has ambitions to create enough
anode and cathode materials
for five million electric
vehicles by 2030.
Now these companies may be
taking different approaches,
but they have something in common,
they're all betting on the future
where these minerals
are valuable and needed
and their plans have come to fruition.
But, right now, the price of
some of these raw materials
has been falling
as demand for EVs softens slightly.
And the more minerals like this
that are discovered and mined,
the cheaper they could become,
as they go from being something
really rare and precious
to, well, pretty common.
(upbeat music)